I'd like to order a private plane
destinations Miami San Fran Vegas
Foxborough what is that noise
it's easy money and you barely have to
play
platypus
why is your body making those noises I'm
doing a laughing Tom I'm happy turns out
during the playoffs everyone else stays
in Gridiron Heights and gets along have
a cold one why to be relatable on late
night TV everyone's welcome isn't that
right Rock we also got catering the
Ducks are happy to sponsor the
off-season dance contest for the 12th
Street yeah I wish overall expectations
were this low could have been worse I
love it here look watch
it's all good I'm about to be Kirk
Cousins Rich look the kicker's brain's
starting it's okay we played Jack sorry
we're wearing hair sooner we
accidentally bait the bugs
really not all about winning yo we're
trying to rest for the playoffs that
we're still in our oh geez
losing sucks everyone get them
[Music]
so uh how's how's Devante oh you uh
didn't hear we broke up oh wow that's
I'm sorry to hear that yeah well I think
you never got over an old flame go to
him Aaron but I wouldn't be Derek Carr
if I didn't love love now go to him
before it's too late
[Music]